what you believe about yourself is the
only thing that matters at the end of
the day no matter how much outside
affirmations you get or other people
telling you you're amazing if you don't
believe in your heart that you are
amazing none of that will last if you've
ever gone to an event or you ever made a
video or created something or you're
hanging out with a friend and they tell
you how amazing you are and that feels
good right but then it fades but that
stuff doesn't last you don't have
somebody being a cheerleader for you
every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that you have to be
that for yourself if you're constantly
only getting your value as a human being
from other people when they tell you
that you're amazing you're never gonna
love your life you're never going to
love yourself it has to come from you
has to come from you telling yourself
and you believe in that you are amazing
hey hey now Carmichael and we made these
videos be
the most ambitious
but you know you're capable of off more
and you need to push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan Carmichael and learn the biggest
mindset shift that you need to make to
succeed enjoy
okay so that's that's a lot of words how
do you actually go off and do it
like for me it's this is why I believe
that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
feel them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our
worst enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people we're not hard
enough on ourselves let me let me stick
with me for a minute we're not hard
enough on ourselves because in order to
get to where you want to go you actually
need to push yourself more the problem
is why we can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
barely hanging on to what we're doing we
we can post all these great things on
Instagram or wherever and make it look
like we're enjoying our life but most
people are barely hanging on the people
who are judging you for your life and
telling you that you suck hate their own
lives they are barely hanging on so how
do we get through it well yes we can be
harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masking
and insecurity
right it's like those people who uh
have you ever seen those memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything and now he's like doesn't
care you know just walking on a T-shirt
and some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masking and
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right
I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
if it came on you would have to you
would have to move right it doesn't mean
that you're up and like dancing through
the whole house going crazy in your
underwear first thing in the morning but
something that even if it's just making
your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's a fastest way to change
your state to go from feeling low and
tired and just what what day is it what
am I doing I wake up every day like what
day is it what am I doing today yes but
I demand excellence and that that starts
with music because I don't have I don't
want to spend a lot of time trying to
get into the right state of mind I can
command it whenever I want just by
putting on the right song so be in
tension with your music and the lyrics
being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and it's probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rocking uh
I'll walk to Tim Hortons usually get a
coffee
you know this costs two bucks two
something so I only had you know what's
the what's the best money I spend every
year well it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
a coffee every morning and I'm thinking
about what's my intention for the day
and I'm thinking about what I want to
accomplish today and the lives that I
want to serve and the people I want to
help and and what I'm about to do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time
so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be
11. first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brand lytics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate I mean
it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe locks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation in somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things rule number two
grow and improve self-improvement is the
answer to whatever obstacle is staring
you in the face right now the only
difference between you and greatness is
the willingness to grow and improve it's
not Talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and Tony Robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who at 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like Jim Rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over six billion dollars
in annual revenue if Tony Robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
college education to being one of the
most influential people in the world
why can't you the difference is he made
the investment to constantly improve
himself and you haven't yet at that
level so I look at my channel as an
example my YouTube channel and I've
learned so much over the past number of
years in confidence and growth and
abilities and skills by consuming the
content because I love the top 10 series
and the meant to me Series in the
espresso series I make them for me and
then I share them with you and
thankfully you guys like them too and I
can build a business off of it and keep
pumping out more content but it helps me
I've grown I've learned and one of the
biggest moments that helped me realize
how much I've learned is when I signed a
three-year deal with sage I was working
with Stephen Kelly who is the CEO and
every month we'd be on a call we'd be
doing a hangout on my YouTube channel
answering questions from people and I
was driving with my dad and I remember
him asking me how do you get the
confidence to be on a call with Stephen
Kelly and be seen as his equal all the
time and he wasn't asking me to put me
down he was asking me in genuine of he
was so happy for me that I was playing a
bigger game and it dawned on me that he
was right
the Evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the Evan of five
years ago would have felt less than the
Advent of five years ago would have said
there's no way I'm capable of doing that
and then when I'd signed the deal I felt
like
it's great I love Stephen he's he's
amazing but I feel like I'm hanging out
with Oprah and Kanye and Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates and these super successful
people and they're infiltrating my brain
on a daily basis right a daily basis
three videos every single day on this
channel and so bit by bit it pulls me up
now I recognize I still have a long way
to go I still have so much more to learn
I still need to believe in myself even
more and every time I consume more
content it allows me to grow my comfort
zone a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit more and the funny
thing is all of these moments are are
little tiny incremental parts of your
growth I couldn't point you to one point
in my past where I said that was the
moment that I changed that was the
moment that I had more confidence but as
I studied every day every day every day
I could look back three months six
months a year and say wow I've really
changed I've really grown I've really
learned a lot but in the daily from
today to yesterday I'd say I didn't grow
at all and so sometimes I on your
Journeys you're trying to learn and get
better you may feel like the growth is
really slow on a daily basis but if you
keep going you keep investing you keep
learning you keep seeking out mentors
you keep trying to get better and
improve not every day will be amazing
but if you try every day to get better
and learn I can guarantee you that in
three months six months one year when
you look back of the person you've
become compared to what you are right
now there'll be a big change and that's
because you continue to invest in
yourself so I'm going to give you a
three-step process to how to create a
customized program for you so that you
can become world class at the thing that
you want to be world class at step one
decide what you want to be world class
at you could be world class at a lot of
things with enough energy effort wisdom
pouring in to you practice repetition
you can be world class at something but
what what like what in your core what is
the thing that you need to be world
class at what is the burning desire in
you that you say I want to be among the
best in the world at
what fill that in what do you want to be
world class at number two immerse
yourself in that environment the fastest
way to learn a language the fastest way
to learn Japanese is not from a textbook
it's not from going to classes it's to
go to Japan you need to immerse yourself
in the environment whatever the thing is
that you want to be great at the more
you are around it people who are doing
it people who are speaking it people who
are living it the more it will rub off
onto you and the faster it will rub off
onto you now it can be a physical
environment or it could also be from the
content that you're consuming I get it a
lot from my own YouTube videos because I
feel like I'm around Steve Jobs and Elon
Musk and Oprah Winfrey every single day
and the more you immerse yourself in
that environment the more their mindset
the more their motivation the more their
confidence is going to stick with you to
help you go be world class the thing
that you want to be great at and then
step number three is practice every
single day you need to practice every
single day it's not enough just to be
around it you need to practice you got
to do you want to be world class at
something right that requires daily
dedication the reason why I got better
at making my content my videos is I've
done 6 000 videos a thousand videos
aren't even public on my channel we've
thrown away more videos than most people
ever create on their Channel and it's
not because I'm amazing go back like I
encourage you go back and look at my
first videos I sucked it was brutal it's
because I said I want to be great at
this thing and I surrounded myself with
people who could help push me and I
could learn from and then I practice
every single day the reason why I pass
people who I considered to be a lot
better than me at this is because I put
in more work because when people had a
hard time finding time to make one video
a week I was doing three a day
and if you take that same approach if
you take that same mindset of I'm just
gonna outwork everybody around me I'm
going to outwork my competition when
they may have a hard time finding time
to do that thing that they need to get
better at once a week and you're doing
it three times a day you will blow past
people who are more naturally talented
because you have put in the work to get
good at your skin also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three keep up with the
change every time time YouTube updates
their algorithm you should be pumped
anytime Facebook LinkedIn Instagram
makes an update you should celebrate
because this is your chance to win as an
entrepreneur everybody else who's ahead
of you who've made it on the old
algorithm before the update happened
they're complaining and wishing that it
goes back to the way that it used to be
it's not going back and the faster you
can get on that train and understand how
the new algorithm works you are going to
soar past everybody else so let me give
you a couple examples of me how I do it
personally one even you being on this
channel I got advice from Mac elean to
split up my channel into multiple
channels and so now instead of having
one big Channel I've got eight nine ten
different channels and different
languages now and it's an experiment is
it working I don't even know yet you
know the growth of this channel has has
been standing consistent but it still
pales in comparison to my main Channel
I'm testing it out is it going to be the
answer I don't know did I make a big
mistake I don't know we're gonna see
right the data will prove out but I'm
willing to go off and try it because I
know that the way that I'm doing it
won't stay consistent forever
and so if it's better to have three
channels that have one video a day
instead of one channel that has three
videos a day I'm open to test in it I'm
open to potentially risking my entire
history 10 years of doing it one way to
say hey this new thing's coming along
Let's test it next I'm working with a
lot of guys like Mark Cuban not mark But
others who are at his level who I think
of as thought leaders but from a
previous era like Mark should be on
YouTube where is Mark's YouTube channel
he's missing it
he's missing it he wants to be a thought
leader and he's still writing books
books are great but you should be not
just on TV with sharks tank you should
be on YouTube you should be on the
platforms that matter and so I work with
a lot of guys like Mark helping them not
become dinosaurs helping them stay
relevant on the platforms that matter
and the third quick thing that I'm
working on is learning Facebook ads
I did not know Facebook ads before I
went on my tour earlier this year and I
came back and I said I'm going to learn
this because this is important because I
had a couple friends help me with it and
it helped and I got people to come out
to my events said this is a
vulnerability I don't know I don't know
how to do this I don't necessarily need
to be the world's greatest expert at it
but I need to understand it I need to
know how it works because this is a way
of marketing that I don't know about and
so whenever something new comes along
it's gonna happen guys the new things
that are coming along is only going to
speed up there's going to be more new
things not fewer new things every time a
new thing comes along you don't
necessarily need to be the first one on
it I'm not saying that you have to go
off and try everything but when
something new is coming along embrace it
because this is the future right so many
people say well I'm not on social media
oh that's for the kids
you've got to get on it if you're an
entrepreneur you need to be on social
media and not just giving it off to your
kid or your niece or your nephew to do
you you need to understand it doesn't
mean you need to be the best at it but
you need to understand it because this
is not just where marketing is going
it's where marketing is your business is
suffering because you don't understand
how to play the game so Rome wasn't
built in a day but it didn't crumble in
a day either if you're not on social if
you're not taking advantage of new
technologies your business is slowly
starting to crumple and I don't want
that for you so I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I use that I
think can help you as well step number
one is say it's the best it's the best
just teach yourself whenever there's
some adverse it in your life something
negative happening this is the best this
is your chance to grow to learn to
become better to win more business to
make a bigger impact it's the best so
when an algorithm update comes along or
a new technology comes out and you're
feeling frustrated because you spend all
this time building up this old thing
that is now becoming irrelevant
the best tell yourself because when
you're wallowing and complaining and
upset and negative and wishing that it
used to be something else
you're not being resourceful what's
saying it's the best does is put you in
a state of resourcefulness
says I'm gonna I'm gonna crush this new
thing this new thing is out it's popping
I'm gonna destroy it I'm gonna own it
I'm gonna learn everything about it this
is the best it puts you in a resourceful
State it's super important because when
you're trying to solve a problem and
you're not in a resourceful State you're
not going to solve the problem you're
going to complain and dwell and wait and
try to make it perfect using the old way
and you're gonna get further and further
further into the cave you're gonna
struggle but as soon as you are facing a
problem and you put yourself in that
state of resourcefulness now you're
you're an entrepreneur you're a genius
you got ideas you just need to give
yourself permission to flick that lipo
bar and you'll come up with Solutions
and you'll learn it pretty quickly and
you'll find ways to apply it to your
business that your competition is not
seen that's how you start to win
number two is model success find people
who are doing it whenever you don't know
what to do people say I haven't grown up
on social media great I didn't either
right you didn't grow up with a cell
phone either you didn't grow up liking
coffee either you didn't grow up with a
lot of stuff amazing that's a that's the
garbage BS excuse for not learning
something new
it's because you didn't grow up on it
amazing
you learn
move one with it and then see what they
did model the success it won't take you
all the way but it'll take you eighty
percent of the way I recently got asked
by Jeremy on my team who we have a
YouTube Consulting business together and
he said are there any young thought
leaders that you follow and look up to
and young being like younger than me so
I'm 30 what am I 39 you're looking at
the date there aren't a lot of people
who are younger than me that I follow
are really I really care about because
most of the stuff that I'm interested in
requires a certain level of experience
but one guy came to mind who was this
Instagram guy and his Instagram guy
posts videos on YouTube and I I watch
pretty much every video that he puts up
as a thought leader he kind of sucks I
mean I need to I need to put every video
at two times the speed because he takes
forever to get to his message it's super
slow it's just not a great structure for
a video because he doesn't know what
he's doing yet it's awesome it's okay
but he has some Instagram knowledge that
I don't have
and so watching him go through I'll
learn something from the video I'll
speed it up to two times and hopefully
in every video will get a nugget that I
can use to help make myself better so
being willing to learn from people who
don't look like you being willing to
learn from people who are experts at the
thing that you want to learn right it'll
shortcut your path again it doesn't take
you all the way to success but at least
80 percent of the way so whenever you
don't know what to do model success
and number three is what I call the two
percent difference so the two percent
difference is when you first come up
with an idea just take two percent
action on it don't worry about planning
we spend so much time planning and
making the perfect plan and planning how
you're going to get to 100 of your goal
that plan's not gonna work nobody's
first plan works exactly as they think
it will be
the thing that's missing in your
business and your creativity your ideas
is momentum you need momentum that's the
thing that's missing and so the two
percent difference means don't plan to
100 instead take action on the first two
percent just get started don't worry
about what the first two percent is it
doesn't make a difference you're not
going to pick the right perfect one
anyway just start and so I look at
Facebook ads as an example when I wanted
to learn about Facebook ads I
procrastinated for months on this thing
procrastinated for months I wanted
somebody else to do it for me I wanted
one of my friends to do it for me and he
was pretty good but not quite what I
needed and I I wanted him to be better
at it I wanted him to be better at it so
that I didn't have to do it and because
I had this okay option I never dove into
it to learn and then I just decided this
is ridiculous this is months of me not
learning procrastinating putting it off
on something that could be really
important for my business something that
I need to learn and if I'm not on top of
it my business will fall behind and so I
connect with another friend of mine who
does this for a living and I met him in
New York we both happened to be in town
and I said dude just walk me through it
just walk me through it and and we spent
I don't know an hour two hours at a
local Starbucks and he walked me through
the basics and I know enough now I know
enough to be dangerous I know enough of
what the platform is and how to run
different ads and how to create custom
audiences and all of this stuff enough
to actually start and then through the
start and you learn you get better you
adapt you make progress you improve
right you get the skills but it's that
first step that's so difficult because
when you load up the screen and you see
something that doesn't look familiar at
all so many options so many features it
looks overwhelming because you're
looking at the big picture looking at
the whole plan don't worry about that
learn one
just start two percent difference
whatever new technology is coming out
social media platform you want to try
out anything just apply the two percent
difference you can learn something
learn one thing about that thing today
make progress will make a huge
difference rule number four motto
success the fastest way to accomplish
anything in life is to model success you
want business success you want
relationship success you want financial
success whatever it is you want to learn
somebody's done it and the fastest way
to learn is to go find somebody
understand what it took for them to
become a success and then apply it to
your business to your life to your
situation the problem is we feel like we
have to do everything ourselves that you
don't know what to do so I'm going to
figure this out right I'm creative I'm a
genius I can I can figure it out and yes
you can but chances are it's going to
take you a lot longer
instead of trying to come up with
everything yourself it's better to build
upon what other people have already done
they could take you eighty percent of
the way it's not going to be a hundred
percent right if you're trying to get
big on YouTube great you can copy what
I'm doing but it's not going to take you
100 of the way it'll take you eighty
percent of the way because if all you do
is copy me you're going to be in Evan
Junior which will take you a good chunk
but at best you're going to be a junior
Evan you're never going to be what you
could be
and so you need to take what I'm doing
learn from it but then tweak that last
20 to make it your own how do you take
what other people have done and then
tweak that last 20 to make it your own
but modeling success takes you eighty
percent of the way
this is the biggest mistake I made when
I was starting up as an entrepreneur
right I told the story a bunch but I was
I was 19 I was struggling I was making
300 bucks a month I'm too embarrassed to
tell my friends that I'm struggling I'm
not having success I feel like a loser I
feel like I'm you know I'm not making
any money not just feel like it I wasn't
making any money and and I tried to
think my way out of everything I was
working my face off right like every
waking hour almost I was I was working
it wasn't for lack of effort I was just
doing the wrong thing so they didn't
know what to do because I was just
trying a whole bunch of stuff and then
that worst day of my life when I told my
partner that I quit
you know I just woke up the next day and
said I can't quit because I'm going to
regret this I know I'm going to regret
this advice if I stop now I'm going to
regret it I have to find a way to keep
going but the way that I've kept the way
that I keep going has to change because
what's going on now this this can't keep
going on if you're frustrated with the
lack of momentum towards accomplishing
your goals in life like if you're in the
same spot that you were a year ago or
relatively close the problem likely uh
could be lack of effort but is also
likely you're just doing the wrong
things you're just focused on the wrong
model and so go find somebody who's done
what you want to do for me I studied
Bill Gates I was out of
pure desperation I was not a genius when
I was 19 and trying to figure out my way
I was at Rock Bottom I just said
somebody has built a software company
before this can't be so hard right and I
looked at Bill Gates and how he started
right how did he start zero to one
that's what you need to study because if
you look at what people are doing now
one it
it's going to be hard to compare
yourself to you if you compare yourself
to what I'm doing now I have 20
something people on my team you can't
like don't expect yourself to keep up
with what I'm doing right now don't
expect to keep up with 11 years of
experience right you're not going to be
as good when you first get started
that's okay but how did I start how do
they keep going whoever you're looking
at look at their Foundation Story how
they started and chances are you already
have more than what they started with so
I look at what I'm doing right now you
know I'm I want to be on bigger stages I
want to get better even better as a
speaker I got invited
a couple weeks ago to be in Puerto Rico
speaking with Brandon Richard on his
stage a lot warmer than here in Toronto
Canada
and you know after after the event it
might keep Brendan you have any feedback
from me this guy has done he does more
events than almost anybody right there's
very few people that do more events and
especially it's at size at scale than
Brendan burchard and so he's given me
feedback
so it's it's like Kobe learning from
Michael you know who's Kobe gonna learn
from
there aren't that many people who he can
actually learn from who've actually done
it who are better than him who've made
their Mark right
who am I going to learn from there's not
that many people who've done more who've
spoken on bigger stages with consistency
right who've been more recognized is
definitely people but it's not a lot
it's a tiny handful of people and so
when you get a chance to be with one of
them you want to you want to tap their
brain you want to learn as much as
possible
and so whatever you're going through
whatever you're struggling with
somebody's figured it out before
somebody's gone through it you are not
unique you're not alone people have done
this and to sit there in silence
suffering being in the same spot that
you were a year ago
it needs to change and it needs to
change now
all it starts with is you figuring out
and going to Google and searching for
the person who's been through it you can
go to my YouTube channels I've got a lot
of them we've got thousands of videos
right 6 000 videos on the main Channel I
don't know how many on this one tons of
videos chances are we profiled somebody
who's gone through what you're currently
experiencing and they have a solution
you know in their struggle in what made
it taken them a decade to figure out is
a hack that you can apply and
immediately get results for your
business
for me modeling Bill Gates I spent all
this time trying to build my business
and struggle and suffering and not make
any deals and taking home a 300 a month
paycheck and then that one strategy that
I took from him which was forming
Partnerships
very shortly after I landed my first
partnership deal for thirteen and a half
thousand dollars and that was the
starting point for my company taking off
because I had one a little bit of money
I felt like I was rich but I had a
little bit of money in my account now
and more importantly I had a model that
I could follow I could do it again and
again close more Partnerships around the
world
and ever since then ever since that's 20
years ago I'm 39 almost 40 now that was
when I was 19.
ever since then the default answer has
been when I don't know what to do model
success
somebody's figured this out
and so that challenge you're facing
somebody's figure it out you just have
to commit to going out and finding that
person and acknowledge like you don't
have to come up with all the answers
yourself you take what they've done
take 80 of it and all you have to do is
figure out that last 20 to customize it
for yourself if you do that consistently
for all the problems that you're facing
in your life and your business right now
Everything Will Change Everything Will
Change that's the difference between
where you are right now and where you
want to be in a year how much you're
willing to model success and apply those
lessons courageously to move your life
and your business forward
and rule number five the last one before
our very special bonus clip focus on the
efforts not the result everything in
your life changes when you learn to tie
your self-worth to your effort instead
of the results most people tie their
software to the results to winning you
only feel good about yourself when you
win if that's how you think then you're
screwed because that person only takes
on projects that you know you have a
pretty high chance of winning at and
therefore you play small for Life the
key is to tie yourself Worth to the
effort to trying and if you do that well
you'll win Beyond Your Wildest
imaginations so let's use me as an
example look at this video right here
this video two minutes before getting on
to making this video
I'm nervous I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why I've done six thousand of these
videos do I not love it anymore nope
that's not it I love doing it
so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through
put this pressure on myself to say this
video right now has to be the best video
that I've ever made that's my intention
going in to every time I'm filming most
days I don't accomplish it when you're
trying something new and scary and
bigger and Bolder most of the time you
won't get it you fail a lot
but I tie myself worth my respect to the
effort I'm trying and every now and then
you'll make a bit of a breakthrough you
get a bit of a win
and the nose accumulate and then you get
another one and another one and another
win and so the answer isn't have a big
goal and then find a reason why you
can't do it the answer isn't dream big
and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
ability to get up and try again and try
again and try again and pat yourself on
the back for the effort you're putting
in not just when you're winning so how
do you do it I'm gonna give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is what I call the
pillow test this is my actual pillow
that when I'm in Toronto I sleep on
every single night and the pillow test
is make yourself proud before you hit
your head on the pillow right before you
go to sleep tonight before your head
hits your pillow you ask yourself am I
proud of my effort today not how much
did I win not did I get the results I
was looking for not that I get my
million views or close that big sale are
you proud of your effort are you proud
of your effort can you put your head on
your pillow tonight and say man I am
proud of the effort that I put in
that's the test that's the test for
tonight that's your test for tomorrow
night and the night after that and the
night after that and the night after
that and the more that you get a yes to
say yeah
heck yeah
heck yeah I'm proud of my effort you do
that you watch your business explode
step number two is expect to suck at the
start anytime you're trying something
new expect to suck don't expect to just
try something new and it's amazing this
is where a lot of people fall down
you've had some success you're at a
certain level you're going to try
something new before you go up you're
probably going to go down
that's part of the experimentation
process it doesn't mean you suck as a
human it just means that you don't have
the skill sets the talents yet you're
trying something new
I haven't brought props in on my videos
before that was a new test I expect it
to suck maybe on an off chance it works
amazing I learned from it but when
you're trying something it's brand new
you don't have the confidence in it yet
you're still figuring out the path
expect to suck when you put so much of
your worth into expecting to be great
the first time out here's what happens
you try one thing you record one video
you watch it back say man that sucked
and then you never make a video again
meanwhile if you just kept doing it it
would eventually be awesome you'd
eventually crush it go back and watch my
first videos come back go back to my
main Channel go back to the beginning
see where I started I've kept them all
up so you can see the journey the
progress of how much I sucked at the
very beginning it took me 350 videos
until I wasn't embarrassed by my content
I was I was so embarrassed I couldn't
watch it back 350 videos but I kept
going
the problem is people are quitting on
things too soon you quit on something
too soon because you're not getting
immediate results expect to suck it
doesn't mean that you suck as a human it
just means you don't have the skills yet
I had to get the skills by practicing
and number three is ask yourself what
would the most bold version of you do I
got this question was talking to my
video guy Danny who came to me with a
really important personal problem in his
life at the time and he said what would
the most bold version of you do it just
came out man I love that
and anytime he doesn't know what to do
he asks himself that question what was
the most bold version of me do it's a
great question because it allows you to
push through a lot of your fears a lot
of your insecurities to force yourself
to be bold and you want to be bold
you're meant to be bold
you're meant to create amazing wonderful
things you want that big vision of yours
to come true you are bold you are
courageous
but we don't live in that land very
often and so if you ask that question
what would the most bold version of you
do today
what it does is wash away a lot of those
fears and insecurities and gives you the
answer that you're actually looking for
finding your calling is easy I think
it's crazy that people don't know how to
find their calling them I think it's
among the most important questions that
you need to figure out in life like how
are you living your life without knowing
why you're here what your calling is how
you're going to serve the message you
have the what impact that you want to
have it's crazy like you can't live a
happy fulfilled life until you know what
that is
and it's not that difficult and it just
blows my mind because
when you figure it out when Will Smith
figures it out when all these super
insanely talented people figure it out
the World's Gonna Change can you imagine
a world where everybody has found their
calling and is living it
I want to live in that world and so
that's why I'm trying to create that
world here's how you do it it's actually
not that difficult it's in my new book
Bill to serve Link in the description go
get it this is the overview one it
starts with understanding that you're
built to serve right there's a reason
why I called the book built to serve you
are built to serve
you're calling comes from helping other
people
it's not to make just a ton of money
it's not just to be able to say hey here
I am on the beach right that's not your
calling it doesn't make you happy those
are short-lived moments
your calling comes from serving and
helping other people you are built to
serve your happiness will come from
helping other people because you are
built to serve three steps to figure it
out one you're who you're one word most
important core value mine is believe
what is yours look through all of the
things that you love this made you come
alive your favorite movie your favorite
book what you love about your parents
look to who who your favorite teacher
was of all time why it's not because Mrs
Jones taught you great eight math it's
because she made you feel a certain way
what what did she make you feel why
right make that connective tissue
between all the things that make you
come alive
and then it makes it easy for you to
figure out what you love more than
anything else what's your single most
important core value is mine is believe
thus everything I make is of our own
belief the people in my life the content
I make the products that I create all of
it has to be around belief this video
the intention is belief I want you to
believe in yourself more maybe I don't
achieve it
but it's my intention every single time
and so when you figure out your most
important core value and then you start
to organize your life and your business
around it it has a gigantic impact on
your life and what you do how you feel
if I was around people all day long who
didn't believe that'd be a really toxic
negative hard place for me to Win It
but since I know that I'm about to leave
I attract people who also love the
message and believe it's why we have
such an amazing Community it's why all
the videos I put up are positive I'm not
putting out videos trash in somebody's
showing them at their worst their
weakest moments why they suck those
videos would probably get more views to
be honest
but I don't because it's not about
belief same thing for you what is your
single most important core value
so look for all the things you love and
then try to draw a line write down three
descriptive keywords so what you loved
about your parents what you loved about
your favorite teacher what you loved
about your favorite movie your favorite
book all of it three descriptive
keywords for each and then see which
word pops up over and over and over and
over again that's your one word most
important core value you have to figure
it out
that will never get old I'm gonna
believe in people for Life Next your
wives who I how your why your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
struggled the most with as a human you
feel the most worthless most insecure
most disposable as a person that thing
you want to help other people not suffer
as much as you did
so Will Smith trying to figure out his
calling it's not that hard go back and
find the single moment where you felt
the most worthless most disposable
lowest as a human
what was that moment
your purpose in life is to help other
people not feel that way as well I was
meeting a woman a couple days ago on the
beach
and she was saying I felt so many times
where I felt low there's no just one
moment so many times it could be great
talk to me about them and one of them
was an ex-partner
leaving her or her best friend one of
them was her father
not treating her well and having some
abuse in the family
it's like okay great let's just take
those two
what's common between those two
different moments in your life
different people around you what's
common
and she took five seconds to think about
it then said I felt disposable
and then she had this pause
and then she came up and hugged me
like every moment that I felt the lowest
in my life I felt disposable by other
people
that's your why that's your purpose
to help other people not feel disposable
and you'll love that for life
then she got all emotional thank me
it's not that difficult
draw a line if there's not just one
moment draw a line between all of the
negative things that you felt the worst
as a human
maybe other people didn't care about it
but you did when you go home and you
felt worthless why what happened what's
the common feeling between them your
your purpose for the rest of your life
is to help other people not feel the
same way
that's your calling and that will never
get old
that's the who that's the why then the
how how you got out of it how you
suffered through it what you did to
techniques
is teachable it's a recipe and show
other people how to do it too you're
still on your path you're not done
growing you're not done learning you
never want to be I'm not done growing
learning Will Smith is not done learning
growing you're never done you don't want
to be but you know more than you did
five years ago and there's lots of
people who currently are what you were
five years ago they currently are
they're living in the hell that you
experienced they're right there and they
feel hopeless and you feel there's no
path there's no exit there's no plan
they don't know what to do they're lost
you represent hope
and you can touch them in a way that
nobody else can you can touch them in a
way that I can that Will Smith can't
because you've been through it where I
haven't and Will Smith hasn't either
you've been through it
and so how you got out of it is
inspiration and it's a recipe you can
teach because most people who went
through what you went through don't get
out of it
they still are stuck
for years or decades they're stuck
so it's the who the why and the how
find your purpose find your calling
except for life on a purposeful happy
fulfilled life
that's the path
and I hope you follow it
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue to believe
I will see you there having support
having help having a coach really helps
so it's not you just doing things all on
your own and then I think also immediate
action really helps you know that when
you get an idea trusted the idea is good